un carrusel de las artes maría carolina
piña
[Música]
bienvenidos a este nuevo número de
carrusel de las artes desde la ciudad de
péage piñón en el suroeste de francia
hoy les presentamos nuestro programa en
el corazón del festival de
fotoperiodismo más importante del mundo
[Música]
el festival visa pour l'image hace
frente a la epidemia del coronavirus en
francia presentando en piñón 20
exposiciones fotográficas en medio de
importantes medidas sanitarias
la urgencia medioambiental américa
latina y la crisis del cob y entre los
temas destacados de este festival que le
toma la temperatura al planeta en
nuestro bloque de cine francés un drama
sobre la inmigración y la desobediencia
policial y un documental sobre las
futbolistas del olympique lyonnais
campeonas europeas por quinta vez
consecutiva en nuestra crónica musical
fuimos al encuentro de david bowie del
grupo night new beetle tres amigos en
modo diversión y locura
[Música]
las piñón en el país catalán francés
vuelve a ser la capital internacional de
la fotografía de prensa en el marco del
prestigioso vida' publimar el festival
de referencia en materia de
fotoperiodismo una edición limitada en
virtud de la epidemia de coronavirus en
francia sin embargo se mantienen
abiertas 20 exposiciones de forma
gratuita en diferentes puntos de la
ciudad
como siempre piñón muestra los grandes
acontecimientos que marcaron la
actualidad en el último año a través del
objetivo de los mejores fotoperiodistas
del mundo en 2020 el festival puso el
acento en la urgencia medioambiental y
en la pandemia mundial por el comino
del mundo es la primera vez en la
historia que todos los países han sido
afectados por la misma catástrofe
seguramente encontraremos una solución
para la lógica pero tenemos otra crisis
aún peor que es la destrucción del
planeta tenemos una exposición sobre los
océanos de plástico en el mundo lo que
nos dice que es urgente que reaccionemos
presentamos también otra serie sobre la
amazonía donde se han quemado 10 mil
kilómetros cuadrados de selva para
utilizarlos en la agricultura intensiva
es un llamado a tomar conciencia sobre
la deforestación la contaminación con
plástico la contaminación de los mares
es aterradora la presión de sergio
lakovic 19 sin duda una de las mayores
crisis de los últimos meses a nivel
mundial una epidemia que ha provocado la
muerte de casi 900.000 personas en todo
el mundo y que muchos fotoperiodistas
han documentado este año dice polly mayo
escogió el trabajo del franco
estadounidense entrarle testigo de
la crisis del cobat en nueva yor vamos a
verlo
[Música]
el rostro humano de lakovic 19 es el
título de esta serie concebida como un
diario visual en una ciudad que ha sido
uno de los epicentros de la pandemia
peter thorne en quien se quedó bloqueado
en nueva york fue el encuentro de sus
habitantes recogiendo sus miedos y sus
historias la cosa que me enterase más es
la condición humana en fotografía y en
los primeros tiempos de la crisis de
comida yo estaba en nueva york y yo
tenía la decisión del mismo que yo sabía
que había mucha raíz que yo salía en la
calle con mi cámara e inmediatamente en
este mes de marzo yo veía que cada
persona que yo en que enfría tenía una
necesidad de contar su vida
muchas de estas fotografías se están
dedicadas a los trabajadores que
desafiaron al coronavirus para prestar
servicios esenciales en nueva york'
ocasión aquí son
estaba con los ambulantes y medio médico
los enfermeros este tipo de persona que
siempre no gana bien su vida y se
aventuró que ellos y serán con
determinación con corazón con una noción
de responsabilidad de comunidad les los
unos por los otros
yo quería compartir esto con los otros
con la fotografía y con el texto porque
para mí el vídeo de verdad de este
momento no son los hombres y las mujeres
políticas son la persona en la calle
numerosas realidades se muestran en
perpiñán gracias a la fotografía de
prensa es el caso del difícil acceso al
agua para los habitantes de cuba una
temática revelada en las fotografías de
la holandesa shane bertsch un manifiesto
del agua shane bertsch plasman las
dificultades de los cubanos para
provisionarse en agua un derecho
consagrado en la nueva constitución de
ese país pero que en la práctica choca
con numerosos problemas en la isla
comunista
la fotógrafa holandesa recorrió cuba
recogiendo estas imágenes en las que son
evidentes las carencias y desigualdades
cuba noche no es suficiente agua de la
lluvia para garantizar
suficiente agua potable para la gente
después la infraestructura que está muy
viejo y antiguo y armas el embargo de
los estados unidos y por eso no pueden
llegar a mucho material entonces renovar
las cosas y modernizar sería un objeto
tremendo y la cosa interesante en cuba
es que hace un año tiene una nueva
constitución en 2019 han implementado
ese nuevo artículo que dice que el acero
comunista va a garantizar el agua
potable entonces es un derecho
fundamental para la gente es muy fácil
decir que vamos a dar a toda la gente
pero en la práctica es un poco difícil
en sus fotografías sanders deja claro
que hay dos curvas la de los cubanos y
la de los turistas ajenos a los
problemas de la gente luego para sales
unidos o la gente que viene a cuba no
tiene ni idea que hay una falta de agua
es un campo blema yo creo por qué
muchas veces por ejemplo se van a
renovar las tuberías que van a los
hoteles se quita el agua del pueblo de
la gente son cosas que en que también se
notan o la desigualdad del acceso del
agua no hay algo muy común que la gente
sana y yo quería era como una nueva
perspectiva y mostrar lo que lo que está
pasando
[Música]
sí
a continuación nuestra rúbrica sobre los
estrenos del cine francés hoy destacamos
dos películas un drama policial y un
documental sobre las actuales campeonas
de fútbol en europa nos presenta benissa
barra con el benéfico único acceso
actual y frascos de trucha de acción
llega a las salas francesas polis de
anne fontaine protagonizada por los
populares y bears disney fija o maxi
ellos interpretan a dos policías que
deben descontar a un refugiado de
tayikistán hasta el avión que lo llevará
a su país de origen donde corre gran
peligro
polis es la adaptación de la novela del
mismo nombre de un convoy donde se
explora la fragilidad humana la de los
inmigrantes así como la de los hombres y
mujeres en uniforme botón sabes para
pintar su modus y el felino y futura
mamá
es como ser de la persona lo que hagan
las jugadoras es un documental sobre las
futbolistas del olympique lyonnais
quienes acaban de alzar su quinta copa
consecutiva en liga de campeones
lewis nos acerca al universo de estas
chicas que contra viento y marea
decidieron dedicarse al fútbol con su
lote de sacrificios y alegrías
a dos semanas lesionado
pasamos a nuestra crónica musical natal
y olivares conversó en parís con uno de
los integrantes de knife new beaters uno
de los grupos franceses más locos del
momento quienes acaban de sacar una
nueva producción titulada phone hours
[Música]
bien
[Aplausos]
[Música]
newby there's un grupo con mucha chispa
el grupo electro pop del momento aquí en
francia los new beaters son tres
integrantes martin luther vikings y
guitarrista pastor izado exactamente el
guitarrista luego euronics europe league
hombre máquina pero que tiene un corazón
y david porque soy yo gracias david
burning por estar con nosotros a temblar
un poco del último álbum que se llama
justamente se siente uno trasladado a
una especie de película filmada
en los años 80 90 una película
estadounidense en california por ejemplo
porque esta sensación es normal o no si
quizás es normal porque siempre en la
banda teníamos como una gran influencia
y de california de los eeuu pero es más
como una onda que típicamente una
influencia musical también es pero hay
toda esta onda relajada no pasa nada
late bajo un poco y yo vivía en
california así que no sé
tenemos una onda un poco blog pastor
norteamericano
[Música]
[Aplausos]
siempre teníamos un nuevo mezcla de un
cóctel de influencias así que nosotros
tres no escuchamos la misma música pero
tenemos que estar de acuerdo sobre
nuestra música así que hay como una
cuestión quizás este álbum es un poco el
más no sé como dice es un poco más
homogéneo y hay este este grupo un poco
sobre todos los temas
[Música]
sí
[Aplausos]
[Música]
es un seudónimo bastante interesante es
una broma pero más allá del chiste
hay algo de david bowie sí sí sí yo me
llamo david marín desde hace mucho pero
es verdad que en el tercero álbum
teníamos un álbum como más agresivo y en
fun hours tenemos una onda un poco más
crudo y hay como si una onda más suave y
quizás es cerca de david bowie que que
que él sabe estar suave es una
referencia si es una referencia
claramente muchísimas gracias por esta
entrevista abiertamente dar las gracias
david aburrido así
[Música]
del crudo
tenía este
gracias natal y olivares y nos
despedimos desde el piñón con un vídeo
inédito de los night new beetle es un
regalo especial para carrusel de las
artes gracias por haber estado con
nosotros cuídense mucho y hasta la
próxima
tú eres muy bueno
[Música]